F: Salut aujourd'hui je vous emmène au Sénat
alors est ce que je vais mentaliser des politiques je ne sais pas
ce qui est drôle c'est que juste à côté du Sénat. On peut lire ça:
Je me demandais si j'étais arrivé à destination mais apparemment non faut que je marche encore un peu.
Je suis sur le perron du Sénat
Je sais pas qui je vais rencontrer
Maintenant on est dans les bureaux du Sénat mais on a pas trop le droit...
de filmer au Sénat. En fait, on ne doit pas filmer quelque chose qui montre qu'on est au Sénat
Ça se trouve, on est dans un petit hôtel formule 1
On a mis un ordinateur, une imprimante pour faire genre.
Mais j'y suis vraiment et je suis avec
*claquement de doigts*
Il est au téléphone, il a un boulot sérieux. Nan je ne peux pas trop vous dire encore
mais c'est du lourd
Attention
Apparition
Et là tout le monde se dit: "Mais c'est qui en fait?"
Et je vous présente Antoine Buéno
Alors Antoine Buéno en vrai vous le connaissez parce qu'il joue actuellement au Point Virgule dans son spectacle Antoine Buéno
A: Oui Antoine Buéno, l'espoir. C'est le titre total du spectacle. On essaye de désintoxiquer, de vous désintoxiquer, de votre espoir
F: Et c'est la joie de vivre à l'état pur Antoine Buéno
A: Ouais
F: Ça se voit
F: En même temps il travaille au Sénat
A: Ouais
F: Tu fais quoi exactement au Sénat?
A: Je m'occupe du... des affaires culturelles et du développement durable
Voilà
F: Et tu vois! Là on voit qu'on touche à la politique parce qu'on a rien compris
A: Les affaires culturelles et du développement durable. Là tu comprends pas
F: Ben je...
A: Comprendre que globalement quand il y a des trucs qui se passe au Sénat sur la culture et le développement durable j'interviens.
F: En fait je suis pas persuader que les gens sachent ce qu'il se passe vraiment au Sénat en fait
A: Alors je peux le dire très sincèrement. C'est à peu près ce qui se passe à l'Assemblée Nationale c'est à dire que...
F: *rires* je vous entends rire. Tout le monde ris, il y en a 3 derrière l'écran qui ont fait "Ah oui il pionce en fait"
A: Ouais voilà voilà, c'est à dire que, oui, pas grand chose mais toutes les lois
C'est à dire qu'on examine toutes les lois
J'ai pas dis qu'on les modifiait beaucoup
mais on les examine
et on les vote
F: Ouais donc je vais te demander de me raconter une anecdote, un truc pas forcément que tu as raconté à tout le monde
quelques choses que je ne peux pas savoir
A: Oui
F: Quelques choses de...
A: Ça c'est sûr tu peux pas savoir
F: C'est vrai
A: Ouais
F: Tu en a une en tête là déjà?
A: Oui parce que ça fait un peu un quart d'heure que tu m'en parles
F: Ça marche
A: J'y ai un peu
F: Anecdote plutôt rigolote ou atypique, marquante en tout cas?
A: Euh... rigolote je sais pas. Je suis pas sûr mais moi qui m'amuse en me désespérant un peu. Voilà tout autant
F: Tu as des mots clés en tête qui peuvent
A: Oui bien-sûr
F: Est ce qu'il y a un objet dans le tas
A: Un objet?
F: Ouais
A: Ça dépends ce qu'on appelle un objet
F: Quelques choses qu'on peux tenir
A: Qu'on peux tenir?
F: Ouais
F: Qu'on peux toucher quelques choses de réel.
A: Ouais
A: Tu sais que je m'attends vraiment à être super bluffé
F: C'est vrai?
A: Ouais
F: Ecoute moi je te fais un petit patchwork qui d'après moi peux correspondre à ton anecdote mais alors euh... *rire*
F: Je le cache dans l’enveloppe pour être sûr que tu ne puisse rien voir
F: Et voici ma prédiction Antoine Buéno qui j'espère correspondra en partie à des éléments de cette anecdote que tu vas nous raconter.
A: D'accord
F: Et je ne connais forcément pas cette anecdote puisque tu ne me l'as pas raconté
A: Non c'est vrai
F: Parce que si, il y en a bien un qui ne voudra jamais m'aider... C'est lui
A: Ah non non
A: Non non parce que moi je veux qu'il se plante la gueule
F: Que ce soit clair
A: Alors c'est des choses que j'ai apprise en m'occupant d'une loi... qui est passé au Sénat
très très récemment c'était la semaine dernière
c'est la loi relative à la biodiversité
F: D'accord
A: Alors il y avait un article de cette loi qui interdisait une forme de chasse, que les gens ne connaissent pas forcément
qui s'appelle la chasse à la glu
F: A la glu?
A: A la glu, oui c'est à dire...
F: Mais pas la glu qu'on colle
A: Si si à la glu qu'on colle absolument c'est à dire que...
ça consiste à mettre de la glu sur des arbres et il y a des oiseaux qui viennent si coller
et une fois qu'ils sont coller
F: C'est une chasse qui se pratique?
A: C'est une pratique tout à fait qui est utilisé dans un certain nombre de département
c'est une pratique historique en fait
qui correspond à des traditions
et donc c'est ce qu'on appelle la chasse à la glu. Les oiseaux
F: Ça n'existais pas depuis des années non plus?
A: Ça existe depuis
F: ah ouais quoi que avec de la farine...
A:il y avais des moyens traditionnelle de coller les oiseaux
Alors les oiseaux en questions c'est pas eux qu'on chasse
Les oiseaux deviennent des appelants.
Des appelants pour les oiseaux réellement chassaient
Et alors donc... on peut juger ce qu'on veut la dessus
alors après moi à titre personnel je trouve ça absolument abominable, abject, barbare, ignoble
et donc... il se trouve que le Sénat a supprimé l'article qui interdisait cette forme de chasse
il y a donc eu ensuite un débat la dessus
et finalement l'article n'a jamais été rétabli.
en tout cas pas encore rétabli, si il l'est un jour et je pense pas qu'il le sera donc
la chasse à la glu dans la biodiversité continue d'être autorisé et l'autre anecdote un petit peu
F: C'est incroyable
A: C'est incroyable
L'autre anecdote un petit peu dans le même esprit mais dans le sens inverse
C'est que... il y avais un certain nombre de sénateurs qui on déposait un amendement pour
que les poteaux... enfin certains poteaux qui sont mis en place par les opérateurs de réseau téléphonique, c'est en fait les antennes relais, donc il y a des poteaux
et ces poteaux aux sommets ne sont pas obturés
ils ne sont pas fermés. Ça je ne le savais pas donc je l'ai appris
et au delà de ça c'est que les oiseaux... beaucoup d'entre eux tombe dedans
F: ah oui d'accord
A: Voilà... ils sont
F: Ah c'est creux
A: Oui c'est creux
donc ils croient à un refuge donc il rentre dedans et après ils ne savent plus ressortir
et donc ils sont littéralement pigés dedans et... pour un certain nombre de ces poteaux on trouve jusqu'à 1m50 de cadavre d'oiseaux
et donc il y a eu un amendement déposé au Sénat
pour obliger les opérateurs à obturer, à fermer ses poteaux et cette amendement n'a pas été voté
donc effectivement c'est pas très drôle
mais ça frappe quand même
F: C'est clair
A: Moi c'est quelques choses auquel je pense depuis que j'ai appris ça
parce que ça m'obnubile relativement
et... alors il y a une forme d'humour noir, effectivement, à imaginer la barbarie et l'atrocité dont on peut être les auteurs
F: Est ce qu'on pourrait pas mettre un peu de glu en haut du poteau
A: Oui
F: Pour le fermer avec un bout de bois par exemple
A: Alors c'est l'aspect très pratique du mentaliste
du mentaliste bricolage
on retrouve cette esprit bricolage dans beaucoup de choses que tu fais j'ai l'impression
F: C'est surtout... le mentaliste qui se dit "alala je suis pas tout à fait sûr"
A: Ah oui
F: C'est à dire que...
Autant
y'a un élément de ça qui correspond à...
une de tes anecdotes, autant le deuxième je suis un peu à côté
A: D'accord
F: Je pense savoir pourquoi
A: Oui
F: euh... par exemple... par exemple je vais l'ouvrir. Devant vous
devant vous je le rouvre
A: ouais ouais
F: et à l'intérieur ça...
à l'intérieur ça... ça parle de travail
l'autre c'est... ça parlait de glu en l'occurence
A: ouais ouais
F: La glu ça j'ai vu
et ensuite je pensais que tu allais me parler de quelques choses en rapport avec les pendaisons
parce que j'avais l'image d'une potence
A: Ah oui
F: Je pense
A: Oui
F: que j'aurai mieux fait d'avoir l'image d'un poteau
A: Et tout à fait
F: Ça m'agace un petit peu mais...
A: Et pourtant on est quand même très très bon
A: Excuse moi mais glu et potence c'est assez extraordinaire
F: C'est vrai?
A: Oui
tu devrais en faire un métier. Enfin
F: J'y ai pensé de monter sur scène
Par rapport à ça mais...
*rires*
A: Non mais c'est énorme
F: J'avais vraiment l'image de la potence et tout. Et du coup j'étais très curieux d'ailleurs de...de
A: Moi je sais que c'est pas pipoter mais tu crois que les gens? euh...
F: Ben écoute les... Les...maintenant  Y'as plus le choix. Faut que vous me croyez et faut que vous arrêtiez de dire dans les commentaires des vidéos
il y a trop de coupes.
A: Ouais
F: Ce sont tes complices
A: Non non
F: Honnêtement non, on a créé cette identité... au point de créer le personnage
A:Non alors euh, pour les gens qui me connaissent, le savent, je ne souhaite vraiment le bien et le succès de personnes, quoi! Donc euh...
F: C'est vrai
A: Donc je n'avais aucune raison de l'aider
F: Bon travail, bin forcément.
Glu ça c'est pas mal.
A: Bin Glu ça c'est étonnant
F: Et... potence?
A: Non potence c'est... c'est Bravo
F: Merci
A: Bravo bravo
A: J'ai plus fait ça (le"tape m'en 5") depuis 14ans
F: Et oui, tu sais parce que lundi dernier j'ai fait une vidéo avec Bonaf qui a 14 ans dans sa tête
et il m'as checké et depuis lundi je fais "eeeehhh" comme ça à tout le monde
F: Merci à toi Antoine Bueno
A: Merci à vous
F: Vous pouvez retrouver Antoine Bueno dans son spectacle au point virgule en ce moment
A: Oui tout les mercredis 19h effectivement au point virgule pour Antoine Buéno, l'espoir
F: Et vous avez dans le descriptif de la vidéo, toutes les infos sur Antoine Bueno a rajouté sur Facebook. Tu as facebook.
A: Ouais,  enfin je crois. C'est pas moi.
*rires*
F: C'est la meilleure réponse du monde, je crois que... je suis sur Facebook
A demain 17h pour le prochain MentalVlog. Ciao!